let's read what papa trump has to say
about cnn timcast.com reports trump
mocks cnn and low-rated chris wallace
over failed streaming service
saying quote it was like an empty desert
out there despite spending hundreds of
millions of dollars and the hiring of
low-rated chris wallace a man who tried
so hard to be his father mike but lacked
the talent and whatever else is
necessary to be a star in any event it's
just one more piece of cnn and fake news
that we don't have to bother with
anymore trump continued wow
he said congratulations to cnn plus on
their decision to immediately fold for a
lack of ratings or viewers in any way
shape or form
absolutely incredible
bye-bye cnn i can't believe he just
threatened their safety like that oh
yeah
i will say mike wallace was pretty
awesome that i agree with him with i
this is like did you could you imagine
being chris wallace and being like
you're at fox news and then brian
stelter walks up and he's like would you
like to do a show and he's like well i
think that sounds like a great idea and
then he moves over and then within three
weeks he's fired
i'm obsessed with reading all the
articles about his mental state like the
updates it's like chris wallace telling
interns to read him the numbers every
hour chris was having mental breakdown
have you not seen these articles like he
was worried about his ratings yeah he
kept asking them to give him updates on
the numbers every day i i would promise
you that tim cast has more subs is there
do you think there are people out there
who are like you know they're they're
they're going to work and then they walk
up to the water cooler and there's like
a dude pouring water they go hey you see
that chris wallace yesterday
oh yeah good stuff i got to see what
wallace has to say you know every night
i go home what is he up to i think
what's his take pathetic is when you
care about what the audience thinks
that's appeals appeals wants the
audience to feel something that's that's
pathetic uh i'm not 100 sure if that's
the only use of it but that's a big part
of what that means yeah it's really
yeah i'll double check all that i want
to look into it that's it
have you guys watched it at all like you
know cnn plus you know jokingly bought a
membership to see what's there that's
that's not funny that's not a joke why
would we do you know
do you know what i can do with three
dollars
i could do i could do so much that's
worth more than what cnn is only 30
dollars they they cut it in half
because people weren't yeah they were
people weren't signing up for six
dollars
so they reduced it to 299
lifetime or whatever and i'm just like
do i want a cheeseburger or do i want to
watch cnn and yeah i gotta be honest
people aren't paying for this like
tucker carlson originals is taking off
you've got lots of these things starting
up it would have to be pretty bad for
them to say like oh we're not just gonna
change strategy a bit
we're going to cut it off right now like
three weeks in it would have to be
brutal like i'd be curious to see those
numbers it was all scenes it was 150 000
paying monthly members
so if you're doing you know six bucks a
month or whatever they're getting
they're not even cracking a million
bucks per month so you know they got a
good amount of money coming in per year
but with a 300 million dollar initial
investment and they were they were
planning on putting a billion dollars
it's warner brothers isn't it just
wanting money into it warner brothers
merges with discovery and what they're
saying now is they're like
because of the merger cnn plus didn't
fit our plans and we want everything
housed under one streaming service and
i'm like oh yeah if cnn got a million
subs in one month they would not have
canceled it they would have been
celebrating cnn plus failed because cnn
plus is garbage because cnn is garbage
and garbage is not worth buying well
it's not just that they're wrong it's
that they're boring there are content
creators who i disagree with who i can
tune into every now and again just to
get their perspective on something about
me but true yeah exactly uh ian
specifically but the fact is if you want
people to pay for your subscription
service you have to have said something
at least mildly interesting at some
point in your life and i don't think
you'd qualify to work at cnn if you were
capable of that look at this tim cass
goes on john nakozia the former managing
editor of mediaide recently reported he
had sources saying wallace was having
daily breakdowns over the state of cnn
quote source chris wallace is having
daily breakdowns over the miserable
launch of cnn plus wants a cnn show or
is threatening to walk they go on he is
having staffers count how many times a
day his promo is playing
whoa yeah pathetic comes from patheticos
which is greek for subject to feeling
sensitive or capable of emotion it
wasn't necessarily tied to an audience
but it was usually because of the way
someone else treated someone i would not
want to be chris wallace's agent right
now he's you know chris wallace on the
phone what's going on with my show
i have a solution oh yeah you know what
i would pay for i would pay if they
moved them transferred all these people
from cnn plus to disney plus and like
cast them in an early
2000s style movie so right like luck of
the irish wait why are you looking at me
it always has to go there i had these
like horrendous amazingly offensive old
disney shows from the early 2000s those
were acceptable everyone from cnn in one
of those and like as like high school
people too since they always cast adults
as high school characters in disney
movies chris wallace high schooler
amazing yeah i mean i'd pay to watch
that to be honest
i gotta be i gotta be real if
cnn plus launched and their commercial
was that all of the hosts from cnn's
primetime and chris wallace would be
like cnn plus was literally just them
doing musicals
i actually would have subscribed to see
it yeah i'd be like i'd like to see
brian stelter pirouette yeah you know
and and it's a ridiculous thing i
wouldn't pay for in the long term but
i'd at least pay out of curiosity one
time to see what they're doing instead
they were like nobody wants to watch cnn
let's put our behind-the-scenes garbage
that's even worse for money and i'm like
i don't want to pay tim why are you
giving them ideas i thought we're here
trying to build culture you want to
encourage cnn to do it
actually i mean that might be a hit show
i'm not even kidding you know making
making them do some kind of musical
number people might want to laugh at
them they went well and to be fair and
then musical to be fair they will say
anything for money
that's true yeah
will they sing anything that's a good
question are they capable of singing we
can maybe throw some auto tune in there
cnn hear me out i got a pitch for you
it's a show
where you get
chris wallace for one hour you get
brian's out there for an hour you get
jake tapper and they have to read the
super chats whatever it is in
chronological order yes so that means
like brian selter would have to read
exactly what someone sends him yo i just
want to say you guys we would make a
million bucks a day
from billions every single one of those
person's career would be over five
minutes into the first episode dude
that's the thing what's missing is the
interactivity between these people in
the audience like a good journalist is
going to respond to questions if about
what their journalism is and these
people are like behind a glass wall but
it's not just the oh sorry no like the
first super chat for brian stelter is
someone would write i am a potato i am a
potato and he'd have to read it and
people would pay good money for him to
do that well this is the thing it's not
in it it's not just the interactivity of
it it's the personalities you're dealing
with do you think people would really
like write in to brian stelton like
maybe to mess with them or if they were
reading it but i just don't think these
people are entertaining or charismatic
enough yeah they're parroting a line of
lies i think for the most part when i've
seen a lot of stuff come out of cnn the
thing is i don't want to say too much
because i can't think any one thing off
the top of my head but it's felt like
they've been lying to me for a while or
telling me stuff that's not true
whenever i've done tv shows i've always
like been like this is amazing i just
get to sit here and say whatever i want
and people on the other side can't do
anything about it you just have to
scream at your tv you can't comment
anywhere nothing i can imagine that
feels like very powerful to them and the
idea of ever exposing themselves to
their actual to the peasants in the
audience who may throw tomatoes and
that's what twitter is
no no no right now i mean people are
saying things about you and you you do
not want to hear what they're saying let
me let you let me learn i don't want to
hear it i'm going to read it i'm going
to read it you think that you can escape
one says
i love lauren southern ah i'm gonna
smash the like button
well tapped it back on shows like this
people actually for the most part it's a
bad day
yeah we're debunking nice they rolled up
on
source
source like if we're really in a
psychological war fifth generational war
and they're not using the best
technology available to them they're
losing the psychological war people
aren't falling for it because they can't
respond they can't get through
i think cnn wants to lie and they don't
want you to be able to call them out if
cnn had a show where there was a live
chat next to it and they said it would
just be inundated with people being like
you're wrong about this you're wrong
about this we get people super chatting
us being like tim you are wrong here's
the fact and i'll read it and i'll be
like oh wow this is why sheamus is
correct tim you're completely wrong
about this is tall yeah
extremely tall
ian created a trend where he explained
that in dungeons and dragons a one is a
critical failure and a 20 is a critical
success so now every time ian says
something they either put one or twenty
in the chat actually my new twitter
image now is uh pictures i saw that i
love that yeah it's incredible wait oh
no i didn't see that i think i saw you
post something and it was a bunch of
twenties maybe i think it's something
you should you go to my twitter profile
now it is probably m stock design on
twitter thanks for making those images
man that is fantastic you're about to
get some feedback ian you're about to
get the thing cnn is afraid
one's in the chat one's in the chat boys
no no it's not true critical critical
miss no no they're only once well
without cnn what do we do where do we go
make another one feel lost well we're
already doing it it's the reason why cnn
is failing is because of shows like this
and other awesome like shows where
people can interact and relate to the
audience
i think and do good research did cnn
plus you know i got to be honest i
didn't actually
look so i don't know if they had any
kind of interactivity they might have
it's just i mean a streaming service i
just i love it was wesley lowry who used
to be with washington post he did this
big twitter thread about how they were
the only news streaming service and it
was a huge bet that doesn't pay off
because regular people don't want to pay
for good reporting and i'm just like
like like daley wire has so many
subscribers he said good reporting tim
not right wing bigotry i'll be honestly
they could have paid their users to
watch that's another model that may have
worked maybe with crypto or something
they did they did that with uh the
airports
well no not really but they forced
people to watch if you know what i mean
you know what i think tim i think cnn
plus is actually failing because too
many people are sharing passwords oh
yeah that's right everyone wants to
watch it you know what i love too is how
uh with with tv ratings they say you
know 100 households instead of 100 you
know people so that way they're like
well households could be five people
and or it could mean that the show
wasn't on at all as if the whole family
gathers around sits on the couch to
watch brian stelter together
maybe in the 80s i don't think that
happens weren't they disparaging him who
like the discovery guys were like brian
stelter is terrible or something like
that
really i mean i got to be honest i can't
imagine i'm trying to think of what kind
of person
looks at brian stelter and says he
should have his own show
like like you listen to him and he's
like we should we should give him a show
i got a mixed feelings about him i can't
tell what is the reason cause when i
look at him i'm like all right he looks
like when he has that really fake
there's a picture of him like doing the
joker smile where it's like yeah his
eyes are normal but his mouth is why is
that i got these scars did he know
somebody like growing up did he have his
dad was connected to somebody my father
was a reporter like chris wallace's dad
was mike wallace he worked for the new
york times okay and apparently like he
got a job there when he was really young
i think his same age as me yeah he is
yeah crazy so did he do really good
reporting in the early days i don't know
he interviewed me after occupy wall
street yeah i don't hate the guy i just
he said a lot of weird stuff and i think
he's
a very very bad person
you know he lies all the time yeah and
he he plays this you know ridiculous
game i think when you're on a show like
that people who are willing to play the
game and be loyal and not question
things are almost more valuable than
good reporters because there would be so
many people that are new hires that just
get jaded so quickly by getting that
script in and when you have a stelter
who's just like i'll read it every day
consistently won't ask questions lies
don't care like that's more valuable to
these networks is that that loyalty to
lies than
good reporting to something the funniest
thing about cnn plus was that it was
obviously failing to everybody with all
the stories that were breaking it was
like a day after it launched they
announced that they were planning on
just shutting it down and i still saw
these establishment journalists trying
to promote it not even seeing an
employees being like wow really great
stuff from cnn plus i'm like nobody said
shut up it's terrible what are you
tweeting like this one guy who works
these institutional journalists these
university professors are tweeting
videos from cnn plus and i'm like that's
that's awful
and but they're tr i'm like why are you
trying so hard to make cnn a thing
nobody wants to watch it what are there
a burger review guy
on cnn plus there was a burger review
guy
yeah okay
i'm not making this up i'll find it i
promise we'll keep talking
well they need stuff like that if they
want to succeed they need to branch out
or out of politics into other cultural
issues like sports i don't know well
they either a have to they have to do
two things all right stop lying uh bring
some interesting people on board both
ideally
but even if they do i think their
credibility has just been so completely
destroyed that that wouldn't even save
them or or they could lie more oh or oh
why didn't i think of that double
tripling down if they came out and told
news stories that were just so
shockingly absurd it would be
entertaining to watch like the baby
right we are no longer a real news
network we are now satire like
could you imagine if brian stopper came
out they would change a thing the
executives realized that we were on the
border of that anyway so we decided to
dip one foot in and see what happens
donald trump did a backflip today and he
landed perfectly on target he dove off
of a 200-foot
diving board to a kiddie pool like
techno music underneath his his
deliveries and stuff like if he really
wants his news show to be popular they
got to put like a dub step underneath
him you know while he's talking i i got
to be honest
if they launched a show on cnn plus
where it was brian stelter arguing with
a duck i would pay for it oh 1 million
1 million percent and then you could
almost like super chat in like with
chicken city and then like brett will
drop like when the chicken's really
winning like the chickens really got the
best of him you're like dude this is a
point for this this is a point for the
dog man
but when brian's winning you press a
button a donut falls down
in the 1950s they would always talk like
this and there was this weird thing it's
like oh golly gee dad and then all of a
sudden in the 60s everyone took lsd or
all these people and they like broke out
and were like why do people sound and
then they started talking normal like we
do we're going through it again with
this industry they sit and they have
this news delivery voice that they do
and you're like what is this
theater this crap they're behind a desk
with a tie on you're like what the and
then you see real people talking and
it's we've shattered that reality again
do you think the cultural revolution i
should put on a suit and talk like this
today's news donald trump did a backflip
yeah weird news you're talking about are
you talking about the mid-atlantic
accent i'm not sure what that is no no
no no no okay
so the news presenters so for one thing
their microphones couldn't catch
mid-ranges as well so they sound very
squeaky and dark like this there's that
but then there's also the acting style
where they were like oh gee pop oh there
was an actual accent that they developed
the advent of mass media i think it's
called transatlantic or mid-atlantic
yeah and the idea was they wanted an
accent that would sound familiar to
everyone in the country yeah because
there were different dialects spread out
everywhere and so a lot of public
presenters learned how to speak this
fabricated dialect and then it fell out
of fashion well the actors they they
adopted what was meant to sound high
class by adopting a british non-erotic
style of speaking without the
harshness of the british accent so
they'd say darling where's my car so the
r's were basically dropped and it was
more of just like a taut thing
but yeah i would love nothing more to
see that stupid news speak just
completely go by the way when they talk
like this to tell you about the story
the thing that happened today it's very
weird can you imagine if someone talked
to you like that and really what if you
had someone on this podcast like well
tim my opinion is that the drink that
you have right now doesn't need those
cherries
and sheamus we'll we'll hear more in
this conversation in a moment exactly
like what but like at what point in time
was that ever it seems like one of those
things where because you couldn't get
audience feedback they just started
talking like slightly more weirdly and
never noticed how bizarre it was
i remember when i was uh when i got jobs
when i got a job working for that for
fusion which is abc and they asked me to
do live hits and i would hear
the other people be like i'm standing
here on the ground in ferguson yes
around me several protesters and i would
just be like i'm here in ferguson
there's protesters around me and people
are pretty angry
yeah that's what i did at my college
while you're talking like that they're
like he goes back he tries to catch the
ball but he didn't he missed it i was
trying to do the sports at like at my
college that was obvious it's like the
way uh vosh talks there's a clip of him
he's like i have been beset
by fatigue
i must rest
well i think
i guess
on the left when we have that study
where they they
they talk down to black people you saw
that yell study
what they like is people who sound smart
so you'll see this a lot of feminists
they'll write an extremely verbose and
confusing ways and it's like really
annoying instead of just saying outright
like the dog jumped over the fence
they'd be like
a animal of the canine variety made a
strong leap over an obstruction in the
middle of a yard full of grass and you'd
be like yeah it's like meant to sound
just be normal
it's like uh it's like when you're
fortunate
and you're trying to write an essay yeah
in your english class and you're just
patting it like how do i reach the word
here yeah they give you word limits
that's part of it too is you need to
fill out a quota of words if they were
just like write me the best story and if
you can do it the short honestly the
more concise and simple you can make a
message the better it is in general yeah
it's funny because i mean most of what i
do is cartoon writing but i've done
column writing in the past and basically
everything i was taught in my formal
education about writing was completely
wrong obviously aside from the rules of
grammar but this idea that you have a
you have a minimum number of words
you're supposed to make it long and
wordy when in reality people want what
you write to be concise i think that we
should begin to talk more like this and
try to use a style of speaking that is
more professional and enunciated because
then people will assume that we are
smarter than we actually are wise words
well tim frankly i prefer the newscaster
way of speaking i think it's much more
intelligent studies show that you're
wrong i guess that people
no real question like why do they talk
like i think it all came from the
original newscaster that did it and then
although he just created a genre and
people didn't really start copying him
he like sustained some kind of head
injury as a child so he couldn't speak
normal and they heard him like i just
that's how he was talking that's how i'm
gonna do it like nirvana came out and
all these other bands started sounding
like
nirvana that's different that's because
record labels started taking those bands
specifically they existed yeah but there
is the story of the uh king of catalonia
so in spain there's the catalan lisp
when i was at barcelona yeah when i was
in madrid yeah this is funny i went to
madrid and i said cerveza and then this
guy goes
no no no
and i went really he's like thie and i
went oh okay and then i said that and
someone started laughing and they were
like
no no no cerveza and i was like all
right whatever man the legend i was told
is that there was a a king who had a
lisp and so everyone was like oh i want
to talk like the king and so they all
adopted the list in chile also
yeah
if they the
so like
obviously journalistic ethics are
supposed to be neutral when you're
discussing stories so maybe they just
thought if i sound neutral while saying
extremely biased false things people
will assume
i am neutral on the subject donald trump
is
a fascist
donald trump drowned 17 kittens
according to an anonymous source
if you say it like that and you're not
like seething and screaming then people
will be like wow newscaster person told
me fact maybe maybe you know would be
fun if we actually launched a
semi-satiric
semi-satirical column that's true
but in like not the right kind of way so
like what what i would do is i would go
to nancy pelosi's office
find a homeless guy near her office
and ask him to say things that were
ridiculous and then i would quote him
and say a source near nancy pelosi's
office confirmed
so it's like it's true but like
not right i love that close
nancy pelosi eats
raw fish a source closer do they do that
do they like go next door to nancy
pelosi's office like two guys and then
one guy asks the other guy a question
and then
because it's totally it's legal right
they do stuff like that but not that
over they have what they have one guy go
inside the building and talk to him from
out the window and he goes an inside
source inside
to make statements of fact that are
judgment dirty
another theory i have is if you are less
human on air then people
go after you less if you're not a
personality and you're just kind of like
this npc have you guys ever watched
sorry random pivot uh best of enemies
gore versus uh gorbadol versus buckley
no oh oh
is a good example of a transatlantic
accent by the way well they it 1968 they
had these debates on abc i think it was
they were like the first live debates
during elections and they just went at
each other and i think they all ended
when buckley called uh yeah vidalia
can i say yeah no no you can't no
you could allude to it there's an evolve
there's an f involved and then the other
f slur was thrown by vidal towards
buckley called her fascists and then
they like clashed and it like ended and
i think all of these other newscasters
were like ooh we don't want to get that
messy that was like too real for us he
also he said he called him that the the
word that would get the stream taken
down and he also
threatened to hit him because i believe
he called him a nazi even though buckley
it was was bucky he called him a crypto
fashion yeah so gorbador was a far
leftist and buckley was was founder of
the national so
if it's been that long and this stuff's
still been happening perhaps we're going
to be all right yeah yeah yeah well they
that you should watch the movie they're
like just fantastic debates we just have
nothing like that on tv anymore that was
like great television yeah he was like
national review why didn't cnn plus do
that i know i know you know you know it
really boosts cnn's ratings right now if
they just had on people like uh alex
jones
if if brian seltzer really wants ratings
he can bring on alex jones
versus
um sorry yeah vidal versus buckley but
with jones and seldom and it's got to be
in studio where they can't cut each
other's mics and stuff like that
and i say do it live but good luck but
that's what they got to do if you want
to step up to the plate you guys really
want to want to contend with what's
happening in reality right now do it
live someone just had to keep lauren
away from the whiskey
i went over there and there's nothing to
me that's easy
what do you mean
there's nothing i've got you know you
got espresso chocolate and then just
hard liquor
i guess you could put the whiskey in
coffee yeah i could i'll be right back
all right thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 p.m and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you